guys I've been working for this my whole
life
guys I've been working for this my whole
life
guys I've been working for this my whole
life
beautifully yep nice really nice
superrabbit
all right this round rabbity your wrap
down so as always uh jared is gonna be
should we start at 16 I my name might be
helpful oh yeah how about um yeah we
started that sixteen eight here we go
sir you said there are 14 missing mammal
cases so well you probably forgot but I
was top of my class at the academy sir
you said there are 14 missing mammal
cases so well you probably forgot but I
was top of my class at the academy sir
you said there are 14 missing mammal
cases so you probably forgot but I was
top of my class at the academy there's
no need in here then I will call me two
o'clock yeah
Jared will be a Costco like this you see
after writing 200 tickets before noon I
know you've decided you're gonna show
your boss you know you're not gonna do a
hundred parking tickets
you're gonna do 200 to show them how
indispensable
judy hopps is for the season guests oh
right
so speaking of guests oh how big do you
want the spoon I go big oh well yeah go
big as well go boom
yeah great with this boom yeah boomerang
come to go boom burger huh
all right here it comes boom I 200
tickets before noon boom 200 tickets
before noon that was really small boom
200 tickets before noon awesome
nicely done Lori you know well done
a new little guy you want to be an
elephant when you grow up you fee an
elephant because this is Zootopia anyone
can be anything
okay so if you can close this up so this
is where mrs. Otterton arrives mrs.
Otterton lovely miss autumn played by
Octavia Spencer
and so she arrives and and so and this
is where you actually just had this huge
huge afternoon right it's okay yeah you
chased that weasel through mousedown and
this is right you're feeling really good
cuz you got this bad guy you're
expecting to go talk to your boss and
for him to say great job and you've
proven yourself now gonna be a cop of it
instead he's mad at you because you kind
of destroyed most of them so he's
smacking you down real good Jennifer
yeah really good yeah so in the midst of
this you're trying to convince him to
give you a shot at being a cop and he's
saying no you're still a meter maid and
you over and over tells you no no no and
you tell them why you want to be a real
cop here because you hit the what the
grass ceiling not now sir I don't want
to be a meter maid I want to be a real
cop sir I don't want to be a meter maid
I want to be a real cop sir I don't want
to be a meter maid I want to be a real
cop yeah excellent yeah you know why
real kind of leave it differ your real
job all I needed no meter you were you I
make two hundred bucks a day fluff 365
days a year since I was 12
actually it's your word against yours
and if you want this pen you're going to
help me find this poor missing otter or
the only place you'll be selling
popsicles is the prison cafeteria it's
called a hustle sweetheart she hustled
you she hustled you good you're a cop
now Nick you're gonna need one of these
have fun working with the fuzz start
talking what I don't know where he is
I only saw where he went right let's go
it's not exactly a place for a cute
little bunny don't call me cute get in
the car yeah
every day all right look everyone comes
to Zootopia thinking they can be
anything they want what you can't you
can only be what you are
Sly Fox dumb-bunny and she says I'm not
a dumb bunny and I say right and that's
not wet cement she looks down she's
landed in wet cement says it right there
and then I say you'll never be a real
cop your acute metermaid though maybe
supervisor one day you hang in there are
you so man to her right so what is choo
ization our Jason is doing parts that
aren't even highlight no bomb up needed
that is I'm veteran that's how generous
this me well I I may have sold him a
very expensive wool rug that was made
from the fur of a skunk's butt oh that's
right here we go excuse me uh down here
down here hi Oh em goodness they really
did hire a bunny oh no I got to tell you
you're even cuter than I thought you'd
be I'm sure you didn't know but for us
rabbits uh the word oh my gosh I am so
sorry I mean me Oh
benjamin clawhauser the guy everyone
thinks is just some flabby donut loving
cop stereotyping you I wouldn't do that
I wouldn't do that it's okay um actually
you you actually you've got a little
there's in in in your neck Hey
oh wait no over the up there way little
Dickens well I should get to roll call
so which way do I owe ya Oh bullpens
over there to the left
great thank you Oh nobody's gonna get
eaten alive excellent that's keeper ha
ha ha ha
officer Hopps The Dispatch clawhauser
can you hear me so how's her it's good
sales new video are you familiar with
gazelle oh she's a greatest singer of
our lifetime angel with horns and oh
hold on look at this who's dancing next
door it's not really manages an app but
isn't it crazy a life like it look at
that oh I can do it in real life no a
sec I got hello nice really good parking
duty dismissed abandoning your post
inciting a scurry reckless endangerment
of Rodin's but to be fair you did stop a
master criminal from stealing two dozen
moldy onions I will give you 48 hours
that's two days to find Emmitt Otterton
but you strike out you zine splendid
clawhauser will give you the complete
case file working on on the graduation
scene with JK Simmons and this is the
scene where Judy is graduating from the
Academy and your character Lee adore
Lionheart the mayor is their presiding
over the proceedings um and so he's
giving this speech so I was a bit
blustery when you say a kind of very
stentorian right kind of big big
personality right typical politician
right and yeah so it's it's a species
giving to these these bright-eyed Police
Cadets about to launch out in the world
so while we hear a little bit of that
good as mayor of Zootopia I am proud to
announce that my mammal inclusion
initiative has produced its first Police
Academy graduate valedictorian of her
class CPD's very first rabbit officer
Judy Hopps okay sorry
oh that's hot jeez that was for it
this is Lionheart giving the speech and
then kind of chiding his assistant as
mayor of Zootopia I am proud to announce
that my mammal inclusion initiative has
produced its first Police Academy
graduate valedictorian of her class
ZP DS very first rabbit officer Judy
Hopps assistant mayor bellwether her
badge oh yes right Judy it is my great
privilege to officially assign you to
the heart of Zootopia precinct one city
center X awesome and that's rigged yeah
that's Nair that's one in the can
bellwether make room will ya come on
okay officer Hopps
let's see those teeth that's a hurry
you're good you know Judy it's it's a
real proud day for us little guys okay
bellwether make room will ya
come on okay officer Hopps now let's see
those teeth excellent beautiful take a
very language Riya nicely done that's
Hawaiian here we go oh this is so
exciting I never get to do anything this
important but you're the assistant mayor
of Zootopia oh and more of a glorified
secretary I think mayor Loewen aren't
just wanted the cheap phone buddy you
just get me that nice bug yes yes that's
a wrap this is a assistant mayor
bellwether you know kind of emoted how
happy she is about Judy being put onto
this case no um so I mean shall we read
like one through five yeah we're gonna
hear anise and here I'll be BOGO sure
okay ready here we go tell me and action
mm-hmm the mammal inclusion initiative
is really paying off
may your Lion Heart is it's gonna be
folk jazz oh no no let's not tell the
mayor just and I sent it and it is send
so I did do that all right well I'd say
the case is in good hands
little guys willing to stick together
right sorry a really good assistant
mayor bellwether a mammal inclusion
initiative is really paying off
mayor Lionheart is just gonna be so Jeff
let's not tell the mayor just and I sent
it and it is done so I did do that all
right well I'd say the case is in good
hands us little guys really need to
stick together right yes excellent sir
if we could just review the book nope
this is Sir oh I'm so sorry
sir I heard you bellwether just take
care of it okay and clear my afternoon
I'm going out oh no buts are you you
have a meeting with herds and grazing
too sir no oh oh mutton chops that is so
sex I was it was lame I felt that door
that was super Lanie
you